an ordinary day that's what it seemed to
be at first never in a million years
would have i thought this is the way
it's supposed to start you were standing
there surrounded by all these people and
when our eyes met i looked away from my
experience sometimes it's better to say
a stranger
but a stranger wasn't a label you were
willing to accept you burst my bubble
and took your first steps with a smile
on your face hey i couldn't help but
notice you hiding here you said and my
mind went totally blank i wanted to tell
you that hiding is exactly what i'm good
at but instead i said sorry i just have
a lot to do right now as i busy myself
with my cell phone
i thought this was enough to drive you
away but apparently you aren't the kind
of person who easily gives up so
whenever i took a step back i found you
coming forward with all the confidence
in the world which makes me wonder how
could i ever walk away from someone like
you i mean i kind of like the line from
my experience sometimes it's better to
stay a stranger i guess sometimes i
think that too just because
i don't know if you stay a stranger then
you're not going to get hurt
from by someone like if you just don't
give yourself the opportunity
i don't know
i want you to know i still love you i
love you so much that it hurts when i
think about it
i know that you love me too
we both know that we're not meant to be
together we can be our true selves with
our current partners but it still hurts
to be without you
but what scares me more
is that the love we share is a secret
the feelings the thoughts are not
something either of us can share with
anyone what is something happens to you
am i allowed to cry can i be at your
funeral does anyone understand me i
don't have you you are not mine and we
don't even see each other but still i
can't breathe when i think about losing
you from this world forever
i love you forever
i feel even when i don't see you we've
known each other for 20 years and we
will know each other for the rest of our
lives
i feel like it's painful but i think
probably other people go through it too
yeah i don't know if it is the right
time or have i waited for too long to
say this but i just want you to know the
feelings i kept inside for three years
the first time i saw you felt a weird
warmness in my heart
i didn't think much about it and just
went with the flow until i realized i
grew a soft and innocent pile of love
for you it didn't happen all of a sudden
i was always listening to you and it
always made me smile i loved your
attitude towards life and how you lived
in your own world with so much kindness
the world of yours was so colorful
there was something special about it
because of the way you filled it with
your various interests without caring
what people will say i overcame some of
the hardest times in my life by thinking
about how you would handle it i gathered
all these words inside of me and
repeated every day hoping to tell you
someday
i know you probably don't know about me
that much since i never had the courage
to talk to you now i'll just look at the
sky as blue as your eyes and wish you
had the best of everything in life
thank you for everything you have done
even if you never realized it you helped
me feel much better all the time even
with only your presence love you so much
i don't know i mean
don't look at the sky
just walk over to them
and say hey i really like you you know
especially if you feel this much about
them i feel like loving from afar is
it's like
it's nice and cute but it doesn't get
you anywhere it's just like setting
yourself up for heartbreak i've
definitely also been the kind of person
who spent far too long
liking someone and not saying anything
and as i was growing up i realized that
like people weren't going to read my
mind and fall in love with me just
because i liked them from afar
and i was always just going to be
setting myself up for disappointment if
i just sat there waiting that hopefully
some perfect thing would happen and they
would love me
and also i got over the fear of
what's the word when when you get
someone tells you no
i got over the fear of rejection because
i realized if i just did it i wouldn't
think about it so much so
and also there's there's no hurt in
asking i mean i've i've been rejected
before and i was able to just be like
all right well that that's fine we can
just be friends and it hurts a lot less
rejection hurts way less than loving
someone from a mile away and hoping that
they'll love you because that's like
long-term pain
so
who whoever wrote this just you know
give them a call bro
[Laughter]
just tell them just tell them i mean who
knows they might love you back this
whole time they're waiting for you to
say something
[Music]
dear reflection every day i wake up and
you're the first thing that i see
somebody different but somebody so real
am i truly the person who i meant to be
i look at you and think wow she's been
through a lot from her thoughts and
everything that she's got i'm afraid to
tell my reflection that i love her
because what if in the future it goes
away what if the person she is right now
won't remain the same what if my life is
all just some sick game
wow
okay i really like that honestly it's
very cute to write a love letter to
yourself in that way and like think
about yourself in an abstract sense
and also very relatable
um just like
not being sure how attached to your
sense of self you should be
like
worrying that
you're gonna change in the future and
like not recognize yourself in a way
and especially with like aging that's
like a big feeling that i got from it is
that like whatever you see in the mirror
is definitely going to be disappearing
over time as you age
yeah i guess i think i would say
to enjoy every like
phase in your life to the fullest i
guess because
like yeah we are transient people and
eventually we die and like i think it's
important to value like every moment and
every like
every way that you look and like
throughout your life as you age and to
appreciate it all and not see it as
something to like hold on to but just
watch it like transform
if that makes sense
for isaiah
my old co-worker that i didn't realize i
loved until he left
i know it's just another voice in the
room but it's one worth sharing
i'm not crying because i'm weak i'm
crying because i'm bleeding
because there's a bruise on my arm right
here
look
you can see it
it's that car and the smell of smoke i
couldn't help you
but i could make you laugh
who's making you laugh now
i need to know that you're okay
i need to know that you're still
bleeding
i need you to know that i still hurt
and it was never your job to fix
i'm bending bird spikes so they can sit
i'm taking out the garbage for the ninth
time tonight
i'm sitting on the floor by the dumpster
and i'm trying to see your face again
crash into me [ __ ]
hell
run me right over
how do i hold your hand
how do i make you understand that we're
both still here
what are your thoughts
very
just
mind-blowing i was not expecting the
ending at all
it's very compelling and it shows a lot
of emotions just reading it
dear someone it broke my heart to know
that you got married with the woman you
cheated on me with i'm better now but
damn that hurt xoxo baddest [ __ ] you
could have had it's really sad when i
first read the first sentence but it
sounds like the girl i mean she's
clearly moved on and doing better so
[Music]
dear the boy with the blonde hair
i wish i could have told you how much i
loved and cared for you so many times i
just want to pour my heart out to you
i thought if i told you that i loved you
it would make all the problems go away
but as time passed things weren't
getting better
i wished you were all the things i
needed i wish you treated me better
i wish i could have told you but you
didn't deserve it and i deserve to be
with someone who loves me without being
afraid
you are my best friend and i thought we
would have forever but i guess not
my only wish for you is to treat the
next girl better than you treated me
it sounds very familiar to me
so often we fall in love with people
that don't treat us
well and we try to stay and hope that
they'll change
but it doesn't work
usually
and it's hard it's hard to walk away
because you want to hold on to
the good things and the hope that your
love is enough
but it's often not
so i'm
glad that they walked away
i feel
emotional
no no yeah
that was i'm glad i did that
the first day i met you i had no idea
how much space you'd take and take up in
my heart
our first day of university bright-eyed
and a little terrified i turned around
and found you smiling up at me we
clicked
from the moment we met our personalities
intertwined like something cosmic
i had never met someone who shared my
dreams and goals and then you came along
knocking me off my feet
our meeting i have to believe was meant
to be
we spoke of our almost identical stories
of how we ended up where we were when we
met i am in awe whenever i think of that
and thank the universe immensely for
bringing you into my life
it happens gradually slowly as cliche as
that sounds
i fell for you before my brain even
realized it and on a random sunday night
the realization hit me
hard
soon i started noticing every little
thing you did your hand gestures your
writing
your hand gestures your writing
you are breathtaking a beauty i'd never
been so privileged to behold and i'm in
all of your kindness every day
i love you with my entire being
sometimes it feels as if my whole body
is aflame
if i were brave enough i'd tell you all
of this scream my feelings from rooftops
and whisper them to you as i kiss you
slowly but i know if i actually did have
the courage it'd only be one sentence
that i'd say to you
i wish you could love me like you would
love a boy
unrequited love they
never
fun
the love is beautiful and love is
painful
and it's just a part of our journey so
sometimes
there's lessons that need to be learned
even with unrequited love and then one
last thing so the person who wrote this
is going to be watching this episode
what would you want to say to them
it's okay to love and love hard
and
next time you'll find someone who will
return it just the same exact way
hey everyone for those of you who are
new my name is thoria and i'm the girl
behind the camera make sure to subscribe
and hit the notification bell so you'll
be notified every time i have a new
episode up and follow me on instagram
i'll be posting more on there as always
thank you guys for everything i love you
all and i'll see you next time
you